le département et antenn Réunion vous
présente lien
[Musique]
social faire garder ses enfants est
parfois un casse-tête face à la forte
croissance démographique de lîle les
structures et les places viennent à
manquer pour accompagner les familles
dans cette problématique le département
a choisi de développer les MAM les
maisons d'assistant maternel à mchemin
entre accueil collectif et individualisé
ces structures proposent un nouveau mode
de garde Luc et ses collègues gè la MAM
des petits fut à
[Musique]
Saint-André alors que mange la
vache lecture chant et danse très
personnel à la maison d'assistant
maternel des petits futé c'est l'heure
de s'amuser cette structure est gérée
par trois amis en reconversion
professionnelle qui adore les enfants
Lucile était vendeuse dans le prê à
porter avec ses deux collègues elle
répond à un appel d'offre du département
il y a un an il cherchait faire valoir
le métier d'assistante maternelle et
donc l'appel d'offre il fallait répondre
à un fonctionnement de d'une MAM et d'un
projet éducatif pour
l'enfant notre projet basé sur
l'autonomie de l'enfant on les préparer
pour la vie sociale voilà Lucile et ses
amis remportent l'appel d'offre le
département rénove alors un local et
leur loue une structure entièrement
équipée et adaptée tout été fourni les
berceaux euh les tables pour les enfants
l'équipement de la salle de change tout
ce que vous avez vu là tout le mobilier
tous les jeux
et tous les jouets éducatifs un vrai
coup de pouce qui permet d'accélérer
l'installation des assistantes
maternelles parallèlement elles suivent
une formation auprès des services
départementaux et reçoivent leur
agrément en juillet 2015 l'aventure au
pays des tout petits peut
[Musique]
commencer mise en place depuis 2012 sous
l'impulsion de la présidente du
département les Mames peuvent accueillir
jusqu'à 16 enfants encadrés par deux à
qu assistants maternels un mélange entre
accueil personnalisé et accueil
collectif qui convient parfaitement à
Lucile les instant mat
à domicile il y en a beaucoup qui sont
isolés qui travaillent chez ell
quelquefois elles sont pas en ville es
habitent plutôt on va dire à la campagne
d'accord et donc le fait de d'ouvrir
comme ça une maison de rechercher
d'utres maternel avec qui travailler on
peut rom à ce momentl l'isolement pour
les parents aussi ce compromis est idéal
pour l'évolution de leurs enfants alors
la base Patrick était gardé par une nous
à la maison au départ et après je suis
rendu compte que il s'isolait un peu en
fait donc qu'il avait besoin de de
contact quand j'ai découvert les lieux
ça m'a plu tout de suite parce que
contrairement au crash municipal où il y
a une multitude d'enfants et très peu de
personnes pour s'en occuper je me suis
dit que voilà mon enfant aura une
personne pour s'occuper de lui toute la
journée et du coup le le suivi est
complètement différent moi j'ai vu mon
fils évoluer d'une façon vertigineuse
autre avantage des
la flexibilité des heures de garde pour
moi comme j'ai une activité avec des
horaires pas très évidents donc au
niveau de de la des aéas qui sont plutôt
malléables pour dans une maison d'ASS
maternelle donc c'était par rapport à ça
aussi pour satisfaire à la fois les
professionnels et les parents le
département veut développer cette
formule si la structure des petits futés
à principalement bénéficier d'un local
adapté il existe d'autres types d'aide
en faveur des Mames volont le
département apporte un soutien technique
mais également un soutien financier
pouvant aller jusqu'à 4000 € ainsi que
la possibilité de recourir à l'aide pour
l'amélioration de la future
MAM c'est important de de soutenir les
Mames car la question de la garde de
l'enfant est une problématique majeure à
la Réunion d'où la natalité est quand
même forte nous avons pas suffisamment
de structure d'accueil à ce jour et
pourtant les parents sont en demande de
place depuis le début du dispositif il y
a 3 ans 24 MAM de ce type ont été créés
sur
[Musique]
l'île pour soutenir la création de
maisons d'assistant maternel le
département propose plusieurs
dispositifs les personnes souhaitant
devenir assistant maternel doivent être
agréé par la collectivité et doivent
suivre une formation initiale
obligatoire elles peuvent bénéficier
d'un accompagnement technique et d'une
aide à la recherche des locaux les MAM
peuvent également bénéficier d'une
subvention de 4000 € d'une intervention
sur la Signaléthique et l'agencement
jusqu'à 1000 € ou d'une aide à
l'amélioration de l'habitat jusqu'à
20000 €. les parents faisant appel à un
assistant maternel agréé peuvent eux
recevoir un chèque marmail à hauteur de
100 € par mois si vous voulez demander
un agrément ou obtenir plus
d'informations sur ces dispositifs vous
pouvez vous rendre sur le site du
département au
www.cg974.fr
I